[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit barbara
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
sowohl bei unserer familie und das sind
einige unserer themen heute
vierte corona welle besonders betroffen
sind jüngere sagt das robert koch
institut und waren vor allem ungeimpfte
seien weiter in gefahr
hoffnung im chaos am flughafen in kabul
versuchen weiter tausende verzweifelt
aus afghanistan raus zu kommen
und neue bahn streiks ab montag trifft
es wohl vor allem pendler und urlauber
ab morgen schon im güterverkehr
wir beginnen mit corona denn nach
einschätzung des robert koch instituts
zeigt sich deutlich der beginn der
vierten welle getrieben von der delta
variante und von urlaubsheimkehrer die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents liegt
schon wieder bei fast 50 betroffen sind
diesmal vor allem junge erwachsene bei
denen viele noch nicht geimpft sind
julia schröter
der blick auf den pandemie verlauf
bisher nach wenigen infektionen im
frühsommer gab es zuletzt eine wende
seit anfang juli steigt die zahl der
infektionen wieder deutlich an zum
vierten mal ein entscheidender
unterschied zu den wellen zuvor ist
diesmal sind es vor allem jüngere die
sich infizieren bei den 15 bis 19
jährigen lag die sieben tage incident in
der vergangenen woche bei fast 87 bei
den 20 bis 24 jährigen sogar bei 94 bei
den älteren sind die instanzen deutlich
niedriger zum beispiel gerade mal knapp
6 bei den mitte bis ende 70 jährigen die
höheren infektionszahlen bei den
jüngeren haben auch mit der impfquote zu
tun während bei den über 60 jährigen die
schon lange geimpft werden konnten fast
83 prozent den vollen schutz haben sind
es bei den 18 bis 59 jährigen knapp 62
prozent bei den jugendlichen von 12 bis
17 sind derzeit nur 17 prozent
vollständig geimpft
doch das dürfte sich bald ändern seit
montag empfiehlt die impfkommission nun
doch auch kinder und jugendliche ab
zwölf impfen zu lassen auf dieses signal
haben offenbar viele gewartet
oliver deuker hat mehr
carlotta ist 14 und nicht die einzige
die sich gegen korona impfen lässt groß
ist der andrang in den kinderarztpraxen
bundesweit nachdem die ständige
impfkommission das impfen von kindern
und jugendlichen empfiehlt ich glaube
die eltern haben inzwischen eine größere
sicherheit sie haben die sicherheit dass
das auch medizinisch sinn macht und
nicht nur politisch getrieben ist und
das ist etwas was worauf die eltern
gewartet haben jeder biggs zählt sagen
experten in die vierte welle ist da
früher als erwartet wir haben jetzt doch
eine große zahl dürfte aber wir wissen
auch dass immer noch viele millionen
menschen nicht geimpft sind und damit
können eben auch doch noch erhebliche
neue infektionen auftreten
9280 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
fast doppelt so viele wie in der
vergangenen woche der
bundesgesundheitsminister findet
deutliche worte für alle die die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen ich kann erst
mal nur weiterhin jeden ermuntern sich
impfen zu lassen noch mal auch zu sehen
dass jeder der nicht geimpft ist mit
dieser ansteckenden delta variante sehr
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten monaten
sich dann ohne schutz infizieren wird
stadtrand hannover vor oder nach dem
einkauf schnell impfen lassen ohne
termin das angebot wird sehr gut
angenommen von tal entscheidung wir sind
hier gerade vorbei wollten ursprünglich
runter zu edeka schoko holen und
abgesehen und kann es macht es einfach
einfacher also das ist einfach da muss
man sich nicht mehr so viele gedanken
machen wo muss ich jetzt getestet sein
wo man sich nicht getestet sein wie alt
muss der test sein ja schon ein bisschen
erleichtert muss sagen also jetzt weiß
wen ist das wenig gewiss in der nächsten
zeit kann ich das machen was ich will
noch ohne einschränkung die vierte welle
abfedern mit allen mitteln denn keiner
weiß wirklich was in den kommenden
wochen auf uns zukommt
wegen steigender corona zahlen hat das
rk ii griechischen urlaubsinseln nun als
hochrisiko gebiete eingestuft ab
dienstag wird das etwa für kreta rhodos
oder mykonos lockt reisende die nicht
geimpft oder genesen sind müssen dann
mindestens für fünf tage in quarantäne
etwas besser entwickeln sich die zahlen
in teilen spaniens die kanaren und
katalonien werden nun von der hochrisiko
liste gestrichen
ungeachtet der steigenden corona zahlen
bei uns hat die lokführergewerkschaft
gdl weitere streiks angekündigt ab
montag trifft es den personenverkehr
mindestens zwei tage möglicherweise auch
länger sollte kein neues angebot der
bahn kommen droht gdl chef weselsky
hans-jürgen piel hat die details
gerade fühlen sich die züge wieder da
droht ihnen neuer stillstand zum zweiten
mal in dieser tarifrunde ruft die
lokführer gewerkschaft zum streik die db
hat bisher keinerlei einlenken in dem
von ihr selbst herbeigeführten
tarifkonflikt erkennen lassen daher
sähen sie zieht sich die gdl gezwungen
erneut bei der deutschen bahn ag zum
arbeitskampf auf zuruf im
personenverkehr sollen die züge jetzt ab
montag 2 uhr morgens bis mittwoch 2 uhr
deutschlandweit stillstehen im
güterverkehr schon ab samstag bereits in
der letzten woche hatte die gdl den
schienenverkehr zwei tage lang
weitgehend lahmgelegt nur jeder dritte
zug fuhr nach einem notfahrplan
dabei liegen db und gewerkschaft nicht
weit auseinander 3,2 prozent mehr gehalt
davon 1,4 in diesem jahr und 600 euro
corona premier fordert die gdl die bahn
will 3,2 prozent bezahlen aber erst nach
einer nullrunde
2021 und sie lehnt die korona prämie ab
die streiks die db für überflüssig
alles was es braucht zu lösungen liegt
auf dem tisch einzig und allein fehlt es
an der verhandlungsbereitschaft der gdl
doch der geht es auch darum sich durch
bessere tarifabschlüsse gegenüber der
konkurrenzgewerkschaft evg zu
profilieren manche fahrgäste nahmen die
streikankündigung heute gelassen ich
habe auch schon verständnis für die
tiefe aber mal selber betroffen ist sei
nervig ich bin gerade wöchentliche
pendlerinnen und dann ist hast du kotzen
ein nächster streich so die gdl könne
dann auch ein wochenende umfassen
nach afghanistan es sind nach wie vor
tausende menschen die sich verzweifelt
vor dem flughafen kabul drängen in dem
chaos wurde ein deutscher durch schüsse
verletzt er ist offenbar nicht in
lebensgefahr mehr als 1600 menschen sind
inzwischen mit deutschen maschinen
ausgeflogen worden ab morgen sollen auch
zwei hubschrauber der bundeswehr zum
einsatz kommen mit walcott
auch am fünften tag nach der einnahme
kabuls durch die taliban strömen weiter
tausende zum flughafen die
zufahrtsstraßen sind verstopft
zahlreiche familien sind aus der provinz
vor den taliban nach kabul geflogen sie
hoffen nun ins ausland zu kommen die
wenigsten haben pässe oder unterlagen
für eine ausreise
ich sage den leuten sie sollen zu hause
bleiben hierher kommen ist zwecklos es
ist eine verrückte situation
immer wieder kommt es an den toren zur
panik afghanische und amerikanische
soldaten am rande der überforderung
drängen die massen mit gewehrsalven
zurück auf frauen und kinder ein
deutscher zivilist wurde auf dem weg zum
flughafen angeschossen er soll demnächst
ausgeflogen werden heißt es heute in
berlin in dem chaos müssen diejenigen
nie vorab registriert und in
evakuierungs listen eingetragen wurden
hoffen dass sie es unbeschadet zum tor
am flughafen schaffen und die soldaten
sich hinein lassen manchmal können
unsere konsularbeamten die menschen in
50 meter entfernung sehen sagt ein
polnischer diplomat doch sie kommen
nicht an sie heran
inzwischen sind mehr als 18.000 menschen
ausgeflogen worden da von
1640 an bord von bundeswehrmaschinen das
verteidigungsministerium will zwei
leichte transport hubschrauber nach
kabul bringen die die evakuierungs
operation ab morgen verstärken soll
nach auskunft des krisenstabs sollen
sich noch mehrere hundert deutsche
staatsbürger in afghanistan aufhalten
die auf eine ausreise warten
so viele wie möglich in so kurzer zeit
wie möglich rausholen das ist auch die
devise des us militärs am flughafen in
kabul die evakuierungs mission der
amerikaner läuft auf hochtouren mehr als
9000 menschen haben sie seit sonntag
ausgeflogen tausende warten noch dabei
soll der einsatz in eineinhalb wochen
beendet sein die kritik an präsident
biden wird immer lauter elmar theveßen
in sicherheit raus aus dem chaos vor dem
flughafen kabul aber die us-soldaten
lassen längst nicht jeden rein mit
amerikanischem pass kein problem
afghanische helfer haben es schwer
einmal drinnen beginnt das warten wie
unsere kollegen von nbc dokumentieren
eigentlich könnten die usa bis zu 9000
menschen pro tag aus fliegen derzeit
sind es nur 2000 auch weil viele es
nicht schaffen bis zu den toren des
flughafens die da draußen wollte mich
nicht durchlassen prügeln die taliban
sie schlagen und schießen laufen
hinterher mit dem ak 47 bum bum bum bum
nächste station warteraum die
flüchtlinge kommen zur ruhe gekommen
wasser erst nach stunden geht es wieder
raus zum flugzeug in diesem takt können
unmöglich bis zum 31 august alle 15.000
amerikaner und alle afghanischen helfer
mit familie noch einmal 80.000 menschen
ausgeflogen werden die kritik an
präsident biden wächst
wir müssen bleiben bis der job erledigt
ist bis wir alle amerikaner die weg
wollen aus dem land haben und wir dürfen
auch unsere afghanischen verbündeten
nicht verraten
es gebe eine vereinbarung mit den
taliban sagt beiden sicherheitsberater
derzeit gibt es sicheren zugang zum
flughafen so dass amerikaner und
gefährdete afghanen kommen können der
deal mit den taliban aber ist dass
us-soldaten die menschen nicht abholen
dürfen aus kabul sie müssen es also
selbst hierher schaffen irgendwie
in diesen minuten will sich der
us-präsident äußern m at wissen in
washington was es da zu erwarten
ja wir warten auf seinen auftritt aber
sie hat gewissermaßen schon heraus was
er gleich ankündigen wird unter anderem
dass die flüge der us-truppen nicht mehr
nur nach doha gehen werden in den
nächsten tagen sondern auch nach
ramstein in deutschland ganz offenbar
ist die kapazität in doha erschöpft das
heißt es werden diese evakuierungsflüge
jetzt auch direkt nach deutschland nach
ramstein gehen darüber hinaus hat wird
joe biden ankündigen dass es mehr
konsularbeamte geben soll die jeweils
den rammstein in doha aber auch in kabul
selber dafür sorgen sollen dass die
menschen aufenthaltsgenehmigungen
gekommen er steht unter massivem druck
es hat sich herausgestellt dass ganz
offenbar hunderte vielleicht tausende
von pässen von afghanen die visa
beantragt hatten diese pässe lagen in
kabul in der botschaft dass bei der
evakuierung der us botschaft in kabul
diese pässe vernichtet worden sind damit
sie nicht in die hände der taliban
fallen das alles erschwert das ganze joe
biden wird wohl auch nicht wie geplant
zum wochenende nach hause nach dallas
fliegen sondern im weißen haus bleiben
ganz offenbar machte er die markierung
aus kabul jetzt auch zur chefsache
information live aus washington vielen
dank mrt wissen
ab 19.30 sprechen die kollegen von zdf
heute live mit einer frau der es vor
drei tagen gelungen ist aus afghanistan
zu fliehen zu sehen in der zdf- heute-
app und auf zdf heute.de außerdem finden
sie dort einen live blog mit allen
aktuellen entwicklungen
in moskau hat sich angela merkel mit
präsident putin getroffen bei ihrem wohl
letzten besuch als kanzlerin
die beziehungen zwischen den beiden
ländern sind angespannt wie lange nicht
wegen verschiedener konflikte seit 2014
schwelt die krise in der ost ukraine
ausgelöst durch die russische annexion
der halbinsel krim
2009 10 kam der mord an einem georgier
im berliner tiergarten hinzu mutmaßlich
im auftrag eines russischen
geheimdienstes und ausgerechnet heute
jährt sich zum ersten mal der
giftanschlag auf kreml-kritiker navalny
axel stein
mit etwas verspätung öffnet die
ehrengarde des kreml die schweren
goldenen türen großer bahnhof im
alexander saal sie haben gesprochen drei
stunden lang über die ukraine die krim
nord stream 2 und nicht zuletzt über
alexej weinen
freilassung von alexei navalny
gefordert und auch deutlich gemacht dass
wir hier an der sache dranbleiben werden
was die person angeht die sie gerade
erwähnt haben so ist diese nicht für
ihre politische tätigkeit verurteilt
worden sondern für eine kriminelle
rechtsverletzung soviel entzweit
russland und deutschland gerade dass es
in gänze schwer greifbar ist jede krise
bietet einen anlass den gesprächspartner
zu kritisieren beispiel afghanistan wo
die deutsche rolle nicht unerwähnt
bleibt
es darf keine politik mehr geben die in
fremden ländern demokratien errichten
will nach fremden vorlagen ohne die
historischen nationalen und religiösen
besonderheiten zu respektieren
stunden zuvor war ganz kurz sichtbar
merkel und putin verbindet viel aber es
war auch deutlich spürbar wie tief die
gräben sind
unterschiedlichen politischen systemen
wie
gesprächskanäle offen gehalten werden
miteinander sprechen ein wunsch der
minimalistische nicht sein könnte ein
paar freundliche worte von wladimir
putin in richtung angela merkel die eine
selbstbewusste eine starke staatschefin
sei und das eingeständnis der deutschen
kanzlerin dass durch die
deutsch-russischen gespräche zwar
einiges bewegt worden sei aber doch noch
viel mehr zu tun verblieben sei das war
ein besuch ohne überraschungen und ohne
wirkliche durchbrüche am sonntag fliegt
die bundeskanzlerin nach kiel
die große spendenbereitschaft der
deutschen die zeigt sich auch noch fünf
wochen nach den verheerenden
überflutungen in rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen
allein bei der spendensammlung im zdf
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
kamen bislang mehr als 84 millionen euro
zusammen die fließen unter anderem in
das besonders betroffene aartal den
wiederaufbau kann den menschen dort
niemand abnehmen aber mit den spenden
lassen sich für sie bessere bedingungen
schaffen sie haben fritsche berichtet
es gibt hühnerfrikassee mit gemüse und
reis um die hochwasser geschädigten und
die freiwilligen helfer mit essen zu
versorgen hat das rote kreuz im kreis
ahrweiler eine ganze zeltstadt aufgebaut
13.000 warme mahlzeiten werden hier
täglich zubereitet finanziert aus
spenden
wir kaufen die lebensmittel damit ein
lieber brauchen beides geht nicht im
kilobereich sondern im tonnen bereich
wir brauchen am tag 100 gasflaschen die
müssen bezahlt werden wir brauchen 6000
liter diesel in speziellen wärme behält
dann wird das essen dorthin gebracht wo
es gebraucht wird zu mehr als 30
ausgabestellen im katastrophengebiet bei
den menschen hier dankbarkeit für die
große spendenbereitschaft im ganzen land
wenn man hier vor ort arbeitet rund um
die uhr gehen die kräfte ziemlich
schnell kaputt und das ist eine enorme
unterstützung zu wissen dass die
menschen uns unterstützen auch mit der
hilfe von spenden ermöglicht diese
temporäre kläranlage in den nächsten
zwei jahren soll sie rund 600 einwohner
in besonders zerstörten ort mai schoss
versorgen seit der flut war dort das
wasser ungeklärt in die aa geflossen
abwasser technisch kann man sagen dass
das aartal durch das hochwasser circa
100 jahre zurückgeworfen worden ist das
heißt es kann zu den typischen solchen
kommen durchfallerkrankungen typhus
cholera hepatitis und um solche sachen
zu verhindern und solche solchen
ausbrüchen zu verhindern wollen wir hin
die kläranlage fest steht die hohe
spendenbereitschaft macht für das leben
der menschen im katastrophengebiet an
vielen stellen einen echten unterschied
und sie können den menschen im
flutgebiet weiterhelfen hier nochmal die
angaben zum konto des aktionsbündnisses
katastrophenhilfe die iban laut.de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser weitere informationen finden
sie unter spenden zdf.de und im zdf text
auf seite 8 190
und jetzt der sport norbert läuft gut
für die beiden tennis deutschen
tennis-asse inszeniere allerdings elf
tage vor den us open zeigt sich
olympiasieger alexander zverev in
bestechender form er hat das
viertelfinale erreicht ebenso wie
angelique kerber die sich in drei sätzen
gegen elena ostapenko aus lettland
durchsetzte
kampfgeist und selbstvertrauen zum
wiederholten male zeigt angelique kerber
in cincinatti diese qualitäten gegen die
frühere french open-siegerin ostapenko
dreht sie das spiel im dritten satz nach
0 zu 3 rückstand und schafft bei 15 5
das entscheidende break der matchball
zum 4 6 6 2 und 7 5
kerber steht nun gegen die tschechin
petra kvitova vor einer ähnlich
schwierigen aufgabe gleiche reaktion bei
alexanders wäre wie es nicht einfacher
für ihn jedoch der weg ins viertelfinale
ein glattes nie gefährdetes 6 2 6 3
gegen den argentinier per jack nächster
gegner der norweger caspar in dieser
form ist er favorit auf den turniersieg
bei dieser us open generalprobe
gelungen europa premiere für fußball
bundesligist union berlin im
playoff-hinspiel der neuen konferenz
league besiegten die eisernen in
helsinki den finnischen kuopio palo
seehofer souverän mit 4 0 zweifacher
torschütze giovanni das rückspiel am
nächsten donnerstag in berlin
die schon 2020 wird es auch in diesem
jahr keinen ironman auf hawaii geben die
weltmeisterschaft im triathlon fällt
wegen der korona pandemie wieder aus
nach der knappen niederlage gestern
gegen den zweimaligen titelgewinner
polen haben die deutschen
volleyballerinnen heute bei der em in
bulgarien ihr zweites vorrundenspiel
gewonnen das team siegte gegen
tschechien in 3 1 sätzen und ein jahr
vor der heim wm beenden der deutsche
basketball bund und der bisherige
bundestrainer henrik rödl die
zusammenarbeit rödl hatte 44 jahre lang
die nationalmannschaften coach und
zuletzt die deutschen basketballer zu
den olympischen spielen in tokio geführt
ein nachfolger für den 52 jährigen steht
noch nicht fest
das was im sport dankeschön morgen bäumt
sich der hochsommer noch mal richtig auf
danach ist es für dieses jahr wohl
vorbei mit hochsommerlichen temperaturen
das sagt gleich katjana das heute
journal um 10 mit bettina schausten das
gesamte 19 uhr team dank für ihr
interesse und wünscht ihnen ein
unbeschwertes wochenende das morgen wenn
sie mir auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend so geht's sommer das hoch
fridolin bringt uns noch mal einen sehr
sommerlichen samstag aber das nächste
gewitter tief ist schon im anmarsch
manfred heiß und wird uns ab der nacht
auf sonntag mit kräftigen gewittern den
sommer vertreiben nicht so in dieser
nacht da ist es meist ruhig im norden
gibt es einige wolkenfelder da bildet
sich auch mal etwas nebel oder dunst und
die temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 8
grad morgen liegen sie dann meist bei
sehr angenehmen sommerlichen werten
zwischen 23 und 30 grad und nur im
nördlichen brandenburg in an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee ist es bei 19 bis
22 grad etwas kühler und nur in
norddeutschland sind morgen auch die
wolke noch etwas dichter aber auch dort
wird sie sonne den durchbruch wohl
schaffen sonst wird es häufig sehr
sonnig besonders im südwesten
und dann kommt die nacht auf sonntag da
kommt schon die ersten kräftigen
gewitter an im westen und die breiten
sich dann im laufe des sonntags weiter
nach osten aus machen sie sich auf
unwetter gefasst mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen und es können örtlich eng
begrenzt durchaus 30 bis 60 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen die neue woche
startet deswegen deutlich kühler
allerdings setzt sich dann von norden
mehr und mehr die sonne durch guten
abend